Rồi châu thì 2, khách 3 mấy thứ là một cái nha mà mình có thể dùy hình và tươi đó là rất là trọng đẹp.
Vậy công việc của mình thì mình cũng đã phá trở lại và sự quyết sâu 2 là 1 bóng.
Và cái lần trở lại này thì rất là được mọi người hộ.
Cụ như là mình cũng được thử sự phát mẹ nhiều người bây giờ những nhanh hồng của bức tế.
Chịnh tình như thì cũng sợ chậu, phải bị giết các khó riêng ở đây.
Lên lắng thậm thì sao về tình yêu, 2 người thì nha mà thì mọi người cũng có thể dùy hình thì sợ.
Và chúng nghĩ là giọc rất là giọc ở cái việc là tạm tế là cả em bắt của mình lắm,
là người khiều mình xuất hiện trước nha ở kính trước, các sự kịt thì mình thấy rằng mình thích cái nâng lượng của mình,
chân nâng của quà, sau vẫn chưa tin rằng là cái nâng lượng của mình nọ đến rất là nhiều chứ kết thân.
Vậy sao là nâng lắm là, thì cũng sẽ có khó khái thôi, nâng lạng cũng sẽ có phải tạm.
Tạc dùy thì cũng sẽ có dựa cái điều mà mình không không như ý, với mình nhưng mà tài tính thân của mình khi đổi mặt nó rất có trọng.
Đối với mình cảm thấy là không sao nơi sẽ bài học,
và đây chỉ là một cái thứ mà ông chưa ở đó cho mình để mình mình chừng thành hơn.
Thì tự nhiên sau mình ngày nó không bui thì ngày hôm sau ấy mắt của mình là vẫn sợ lại.
Nếu như mình có tập trung vào cái phía, có những hay nó không như ý,
và mình cứu đi nó ai hưởng hài để cái tâm trọng của mình, cái tính thân của mình.
Thì nó sẽ không có thể nói lượng tốt, lọc vìt là không tốt cho mình và tốt cho những cái người mà biết cạnh mình.
Mình cũng hay mấy mắn khi mà hiết tại ở bên cạnh cho thì có chim của mình là những cái người mà,
có rất là biết cách làm sao để sự cạnh đăng lượng cho hiểu là chưa cần gì.
Nếu cho lọc với người mà sẽ ở bên cạnh mình cũng này và anh rồi luôn.
Thì có không bao, quên gì mình nhiều, anh luôn nói rằng anh tìm là tất cả,
như cái chuyện này không có gì em tảm thú của tui qua được.
Thì khi mọi người quá tinh mình thì mình không lợng là cho mọi người.
Mỗi cái lòng tìm đó, mấy sẽ em tìm cách để mình có tui qua,
cái năng lượng của mình rất là cũng chẳng gì mình được bao quanh,
mời thì phải tìm yêu thương và cái lòng tìm của mọi người.